Hello can you hear me nowAll right.
I guess now it's time to see if the agent
can hear me as well see if that's working
It definitely should be cuz you know it's
not anything that I created
All right
So I want to start a conversation but I want
to do within this conversation is I want to
simulate a meeting between a CEO of Auto
dream.os
AndI want to I want the topic of the
meeting. To be about.
I want the topic of the meeting to be about
the future direction of
The project what we have nowAnd.
The roadmap
Just let me know
All right let's roll with it imagine you got
that CEO directions
It's orchestrating agents it's got a solid
feedback loop and it's doing continuous
execution there you shipped into the Future
Vision systems we wanted to be the go to
blueprint by voting work clothes something
that just run seamlessly and is almost a
household name and automation space
Then you lay off the road map in the next 6
months maybe we're focusing on stability and
expanding features over the next year or two
we're looking at scaling up maybe bring it
in more Integrations and ensuring that the
system can be used but
And of course you finish with a sense of
mission
Ultimately we want to make sure this is a
system that not only evolves on its own but
most people reach a point where they have
the freedom to do what they want
And so it definitely seems like I'm spot on
Without even having to talk or run the
simulation I guess we should go deeper into
the simulation suppose we were to introduce
different advisors and so we have a round
table could be there would be at the round
table who do we need to be in attendance at
this strategy meeting
Absolutely let's ask some characters to this
virtual round table so in this imaginary
strategy meeting you probably want a few key
advises around the table first off you want
a lead engineer or the chief technical
officer this is the person who knows nuts
and bolts of everything is running under the
hood they can talk about the technical
feasibility of the road map and what kind of
engineering hurdles you might
Then you might bring in a product strategist
or product management
You probably also want a financial advisor
or a business development lead someone who
can talk about funding sustainability and
how you turn this into something that
actually makes money over time and maybe one
more thing at the table could be for someone
focused on user experience or community
building things about how people are
actually going to interact with it and how
you work Community around it
So and it's imaginary meeting you have a
nice little round table of your Technique
Absolutely so that gives you a good picture
of who will be running a table you got your
Tech lead your product strategist your
financial a business mind and someone
thinking about user experience and community
and all of them will be giving you different
angles on the future direction of the
project so with that you got a nice little
round of simulation going
Oh that's a whole different kind of meeting
scenario but no worries we'll just imagine
everyone just let me know
Right no I don't know what you just heard on
that one but what I would like to do at this
point is identify what would be considered
Or let me put it like this Steve Jobs was
80% signal and 20% noise what would our
portionants be what's our ratio when you
look at that and don't forget like in this
meeting we can get the cursor swarm agents
to give you a state of the project so that
you can have updated contacts on where we
are if you need that just let me know
Got it loud and clear and no worries about
the little audio pickup sometimes things
just come through funny so let's break it
down in terms of that signal to noise ratio
if Steve Jobs was 80% signal and 20% noise
we can definitely think about where you and
your project stand given the way your
structuring things I'd say you're aiming for
pretty high signal ratio maybe you're
something like 75% signal and 25% noise or
maybe even a bit higher depending on how
clean a streamlined you want those workflows
Louie if you want to pull in the curses warm
agency at any point and have them give a
quick state of the project update just let
me know we can definitely send me like that
and that way you'll have all the context you
need to figure out exactly where your signal
storage ratio stands
I don't think he even likes the colors I
don't think she likes the color green
He tried to stay away from being green so I
haven't seen so much I think she don't like
to celebrate
Like blue that isBecause.
And then when you drop the Box you get
popped and got it picked the box back up
It's actually excruciatingCuz you don't want
to drop the box but the Box get heavy.
And the more you do the heavier the Box end
up being the start which make it harder to
hold up
It's okay though he going to have a chest
and and we're going to stop
If you don't then it just scale over time it
just keep scaling until it finally get
checked cuz like I said like I was saying it
don't matter what you say
That's why I keep saying that it matter what
you do and if you keep bringing home with
you not supposed to bring home then you
can't tell me you care
That don't mean shit
And then went back and did the same shit
yeah because that's his prerogative control
like we're not laughing with you we're
laughing at you
No no no the worst that like like I said and
the worst thing about it is they going to
just keep doing worse stuff until you
finally get it that that's that's the thing
like you you don't want to get but they
going to break but but just it's just easier
To just go ahead just my name is Kunta we
all had to learn it
OK Google
Oh you really thinkOh okay babe.
Every time I say that it's like okay you
might have went like I heard him saying I
feel bad for you last night tonight I don't
care though tonight probably not you give up
sleeping I might end up punishment right
before the time to go back to school fucking
with my ass like you really lucky
With me cuz if you
Were and I want you to hear this cuz if you
was fucking with me you being punishment
right now like right now like right now in
punishment position
Let me know Chris in Charlie
When I hear him I'll be thinking of you
He remind me of myself I remember them days
with Christian God damn Charlie and you see
where we at I should have never gave up so
don't don't give up cuz I see what happened
It's that important you see you deal with
Chris and Charlie that's what happened
Mighty gave up on your ass we see what
happened
No no no I don't want to hear that shit
either cuz see they be trying to me
Google
Yeah yeahBut once they get it.
I was broken
I don't know I don't know what broke me but
I knew I was broke cuz when I missed the
school bus
I ain't even going onYeah now see it.
My ass mama I missed the boys well you
better walk I ain't walk you and Kiki grew
up there
Come homeCatching the Metro.
You got to walk huh
Remember what my legs itchy with you after
school bus tonight question mark
I was like 10 minutes away by Foot Locker
fucking Adventure but I don't think me
having a car would have helped me
But I'm not going to lie to you I know right
now
Always changeYour.
On the TVPunished somehow.
You need to be at school with him during the
day I wish
It's been ended up happening that's going to
end up here that's going to be the solution
you have to stick with that boy on that last
hour right when he start acting up cuz it's
right around the same time it's right around
the same time you can tell when he's like oh
he changing anything
School just started you did do the last
second check like right before he got out
like yeah I'm going to get a good day today
right so so he was like
Yeah hell no hell no hell no I'm going to
have a good day I said you sure you promise
you going to have a good day yes my mama
have a good day and then immediately went in
there and lied
You came home in the kitchen called me at
8:56 so the moment you
Had those back off and everythingI see the
number.
And it said Texarkana ain't nobody calling
me to take the car
So every timeI want to.
I want it to be where I don't have to but at
this point I'm going to have to start saving
the teacher number to my phone
It's safe to be going on a field trip on the
12th of December wait they let them go on a
field trip no he not I tried to sign up to
be a short chaperone so hopefully they
choose me
You would think they would right because I
got the bad child or if he's going then yeah
yeah I want her right that way when he went
to Google cuz I wonder what he do that if
y'all was sitting right there I know he will
already know you wouldn't do that shit right
now
Know you had left but I lucky you didn't
spend the block on that ass
Boy boy that's what I'm saying no just
imagine you forgot it backpack Daddy
Nothing
I like that kind of stuff though you like
the attention
My mama
When I was being disrespectful to the
teacher she couldn't handle what she said
call her baby
ThatEverything.
Outside boot camp
Us
Or put them in a Catholic school where they
what they asked where they can hit him with
that ruler when he want to act like you
don't want to listen cuz that you got them I
don't place that started acting right
immediately if the teachers could just do
that
You would have no problemsBut he know they
can't so.
Jordan Jordan really remember it think about
it at the beginning
So having a good time yeah he just having a
good timeLike I said he just let off the.
Let off the wheel but this cuz it's not his
first year though rightOh it is.
That's exactly why
Work and stuff
So at this point she's letting them hit each
other back and somebody get you them back
like
That's that's not how School works because
he's going to go to school and I said that
So he's going to go to school thinking that
he can go and hit somebody you can't and
recently he just got in trouble he didn't
hit him but he like he said he put his arms
His arm in the hell up basically he put the
kids arm in the hell up
Show me how you get colder the other day
come hereHow'd you do it.
He did that right now the problem was that
you were touching somebody he said I didn't
mean anybody I didn't hit anybody but you
still
Touched him when your hands supposed to be
behind your headNo.
My thing is that it feels like he's taking
most of the stuff from the daycare and bring
it into the pool
And we didn't let him know until yesterday
but it's not the same like you you have to
listen and learn at school that daycare was
a daycare for them to watch you doing
Everything you want there forget that shit
don't don't bring that shit to this school
clearly
Clearly but he's still not getting it it's
all right
Yeah it's it's not a game eventually
I said that it's not that at this point at
this point like I said it's just a matter of
time and how long he's willing to keep
having days like this instead of days where
he could be playing zombies or things like
that like the reason he's standing here
instead of playing a game right now it's
because he's in trouble
Otherwise he could be playing a game
watching TV doing you know anything else
instead this tablet
Okay I'm coming up to
The night Uncle Victor
Them in my kitchen is clean
Send me my kitchens clean